i've been moving my stuff you've been
moving your ship you've been moving
period
right yeah it's been moving house oh my
god it's
so long yeah how's how's that been going
for you
very long
i mean people people on twitter were
asking and people coming into my streams
being like chrono's not streaming right
now everyone's like what he doesn't
stream for like 10 days i miss it
kind of like no subs when i come back
yeah it's so sad you have to work from
the ground up but like you're pretty
much fully moved in right like you're
out of your way yeah i've i've fully
moved like a week ago but then i went
away for like five days as well and also
i didn't have any furniture and then it
all came and it's taking up all of my
living room so like building stuff is
such a nightmare yeah go like jenga
stuff out of the way and then build it
but then it takes up a lot of room
because the boxes obviously were tightly
packed yeah you got to like move the
boss in another room right here yeah
yeah so it's like every time i feel like
i make any progress something else turns
up that i got to do and i'm like [ __ ]
something
i just have a bed now oh yeah it's a
nice bed you got the koala there yeah
yeah yeah i did yeah like taking care of
all the [ __ ] cardboard that's been
building oh my god yeah because you know
in the uk you could just you know fill
up your car yeah drive down to the local
recycling center and chuck all the
cardboard yeah yeah pretty pretty easy
really yeah but in japan you can't do
that you have to put it in your you
recycle it in your building and actually
on a specific day actually you might be
able to take it um somewhere but i don't
have a car yeah and also i'm not renting
a car just to take cardboard but luckily
the new place i moved into you can just
put them out at any time oh that's good
and there's like a whole area for trash
downstairs like an inside area yeah
because my previous place it was put
outside yeah so you could only put it on
like wednesday at 8am yeah my current
place is like that as well yeah i hated
that because i was like [ __ ] dude i got
[ __ ] to do man see my place though it
says you need to take everything out
before 8 a.m
at my place they don't come to pick it
up till like 2 p.m yeah oh yeah they did
that too yeah so i'm just like i'll just
[ __ ] take it out in the morning
they used to in my old place they i when
i first moved in they were like you have
to wake up at 7am to take up the trash
yeah i'm waking up at 7am i'll stay up
till like 4am and do it yeah yeah waking
up with seven [ __ ] off yeah like are you
serious i mean it's gotten me to like
get a good sleep schedule at least like
i wake up nice and early in the morning
to get [ __ ] done but that's not a good
thing to wake up yeah yeah well yeah oh
yeah wake up i can't wait to go [ __ ]
take out my smelly garbage you get used
to it after a while honestly but then uh
yeah the new place is great you can just
chuck it out anytime there's like
normally the the more
modern apartment buildings you can just
like
go downstairs and there'll be an area
yeah
our old office had that yeah yeah
because it wasn't you but you were
building yeah the trash station was
super good it was it's basically like
that it's like identical right um but
there's like a separate room for like
stinky trash i guess
like burnable yeah
yeah so there's just like another room
for that i mean i guess that's good
right like because you know you don't
have to [ __ ] your nose don't have to
struggle when you take cardboard out
right it's so weird though there's like
my room has like this really like
massive security camera that points at
the trash and i'm guessing it's to stop
uh you from doing anything strange right
like putting trash that you shouldn't
yeah and there is literally like black
and white tape all over this room like
it looks like a murder room and i think
it's on purpose to scare you right to
make you not feel like you're it's okay
to like whatever you do
i think trashing stuff you shouldn't be
trashing there
are like weirdos
right in japan yeah it's very specific
so like plastic bottles can't go with
plastic yeah it has to very specifically
go with plastic bottles yeah there's a
whole nother area for that yeah and
there's pl and cardboard can't go with
paper paper is another thing and paper
is burnable yeah it's no no it's it's in
my place it's not all right it's
recyclable oh yeah
yeah some places it's burnable but also
depends on the size of the paper if it's
too small it's not you can't put it in
the thing it's really [ __ ] weird
there are so many rules and you most of
them you have to follow and all of these
rules as well changes depending on where
you are yeah yeah you can live in the
same you can live in tokyo but every
municipality in tokyo has a different
rule
and like you know so also like batteries
is very specific you can only go in a
certain place so all this stuff is very
confusing um and and there should be no
matter where you live in tokyo or
saitama or chiba or any of those places
there should be an english guide yeah
yeah you normally all have that you
usually get an english guide at the town
hall when you move in yeah it's very
confusing because sometimes the material
isn't covered so like cardboard is good
but cardboard pizza boxes no no no
because it's been greasy yeah
i actually have an app yeah that where
if i type in a certain thing then it
tells me what day to take it out
so if i'm not sure then i go to my app i
type in you know like yeah because i
remember one time it was like uh there
was like a specific type of styrofoam
it's not like the it's not like the hard
like squeaky styrofoam
yeah yeah yeah yeah
so i was like [ __ ] i don't know what
that is so i looked it up on the app and
it was on a completely different day i
was like oh thank god wait really yeah i
put that in burnable well i don't know
maybe my municipal is different
styrofoam is just the one thing when i'm
just like where does this go i'm just
like styrofoam is portable right some
some types of styrofoam is vulnerable
recyclable plastics
it completely changes where you are yeah
sometimes it's all burnable
i just put like eight bags
sometimes it's all burnable sometimes
you knock on your door the police are
going to come in and just like so excuse
me are you the gaijin that threw out all
of those
they're just having a haunch imagine
being the guy
that just like throughout all the
burnables in the wrong place there's a
lot of foreigners in my building as well
so it's like i don't feel like the odd
one out